bonjour c'est monsieur breux alors
aujourd'hui on a réalisé une vidéo pour
parler du nouveau smartphone dopo le rx
17 trop bon aujourd'hui on va tester un
produit tout nouveau un produit qui
vient de sortir justement aujourd'hui le
16 novembre c'est le hope au rx 17 pro
tout nouveau smartphone de peau non je
sais pas si vous avez suivi au pot est
arrivé il ya très très longtemps en
france avec un phénix qui a fait
beaucoup parler nuit un smartphone qui
est complètement hallucinante et
l'ajustement le sort d'autres
smartphones qui sont hyper hyper hyper
cool hyper hyper bien placé et il ya le
x10 est pro contest toujours de lloret
testé très bientôt
le rx 17 nés au plus tôt courant tout
cas parce qu'ils sont pleins de bonnes
techno intéressante donc ce qu'on va
commencer par faire tout de suite c'est
déjà un petit peu ouvrir la boîte on a
regardé ce cadran et puis on va avancer
on a testé on va regarder la photo la
vidéo le quator d'empreinte digitale
intégrée à l'écran comme dans votre +6 t
comme dans le maiden pro il ya pas mal
de trucs hyper cool donc on y va
maintenant rx 17 projets j'aime beaucoup
cet effet avec reflets au niveau des
lumières ça fait penser un petit peu au
dos et reese et on verra ce qui existe
plusieurs finitions au niveau du dos
c'est pas le modèle irisé que j'ai la
haine maintenant je trouve ça vraiment
très sympa bon boîte très joli logo pour
l'heure c'est un modèle de presque a
déjà été ouverts donc vous inquiétez pas
soyez rassurés lorsque je vais ouvrir
c'est tout simplement modèle de presse
ça pareil finition très très joli ça
s'ouvre un petit peu comme un tiroir
ça c'est vraiment hyper hyper m'a
regardé waouh
j'adore ce design j'adore vraiment
design je trouve que au poids vraiment
très très bien réussi sa copie là dessus
vous avez un dos qui est légèrement
incurvé de chaque côté corning gorilla
glass 6 donc franchement très très
résistant vous voyez pas de capteur
d'empreintes digitales parce que le
capteur d'empreintes digitales se situe
sous l'écran petites gouttes
ici on voit des encoches de plus en plus
fines comme vous avez sur le may 20
comme vous avez sur le wan pucistes et
débord qui sont vraiment très très très
faim sur le côté c'est vraiment un
borderless je trouve que le design est
vraiment irréprochable vraiment une
toute petite bordure en bas c'est
vraiment extrêmement fins écran est
vraiment cool alors bon c'est fluide de
toute façon au pot maîtrise son sujet
depuis très longtemps
c'est franchement hyper hyper hyper
agréable sur le côté droit vous avez le
bouton pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre de
l'autre côté le bouton de volume
en bas le tiroir de cartes sim ici pas
de carte micro sd pas du tout extensible
de l'usb type c'est un petit haut
parleur qui se situe là et sur le dessus
vous avez absolument rien j'aime
beaucoup ce smartphone pour qui se tient
franchement vraiment bien en main alors
après ce que je vais vous dire il faut
vraiment faire attention protéger le
mettez une coque de protection
même si on est sur un gorilla glass
hisse donc résistants ça va pas dire
qu'il faut le faire tomber pour autant
on peut le casser c'est un dos en verre
même si c'est pas non plus le plus
glissant du monde fait quand même hyper
gafla on en extérieur il fait
franchement un temps magnifique
l'écran est vraiment hyper hyper hyper
lumineux on ne voit vraiment bien je
veux mettre maintenant en plein soleil
j'ai poussé la luminosité à fond et
franchement on voit très bien alors je
sais pas si vous en rendez bien compte
directement vous au travers la caméra
mais moi en regardant comme ça j'ai
vraiment un confort de visionnage de
tous les côtés je trouve que là dessus
il ya vraiment un excellent boulot
qu'ils étaient faits de la part de pau
je trouve que c'est un vrai bord à bord
c'est un vrai beau bord à bord même un
peu dur à dire mais ça fonctionne très
très bien l'écran est vraiment cool
après là dessus on a un seul
haut-parleur qui ici haut parleur mono
mais par contre il ya du son ça marche
bien alors à l'intérieur de la boîte
qu'est-ce qu'on a encore ça c'est quoi
on doit avoir une coque de protection
transparente un peu bleuté même beaucoup
bleuté bon c'est vraiment de la coque je
dirais l'histoire d'abord une coque
c'est pas génial ça gâche un peu le
paysage mais en tout cas c'est plutôt
cool qu'elle soit là ici qu'est ce qu'on
a on a un guide d'information on a de
quoi ouvrir notre tiroirs de cartes sim
bloc de recharge rapide ici au pot on
ensuite des écouteurs connecter
directement en usb type ses pouvoirs
c'est la même famille que que one plus
parce que vous avez là les mêmes
systèmes décroche que dans le one + 6 t
ou en plus 6 pour les verrouiller vous
avez plusieurs possibilités soit faire
un schéma soit ap bangkok soit utiliser
le capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
est situé sous l'écran comme on assure
le le m 23 ans qu'on a sur le wan +6
taylor le capteur d'empreintes digitales
situé sous l'écran fonctionne plutôt pas
mal ça les verrouille assez rapide non
mais ça va pas aussi vite qu'un capteur
d'empreintes digitales un peu plus
traditionnel comme ce qu'on avait
l'arrière des smartphones si en plus
vous activer la reconnaissance de visage
que vous couplez le capteur d'empreintes
digitales
la reconnaissance de visages ça va
extrêmement vite c'est cool en plus
petites options de sécurité qui est
assez rigolote là dessus c'est à dire
que vous pouvez activer le
déverrouillage de la connaissance de
votre visage mais ne pas permettre que
sade et les rouges lorsque vos yeux se
sont fermés
c'est à dire si quelqu'un pique votre
téléphone lundi que vous dormez le met
dans votre tête se déverrouille rappaz
petite question de sécurité
maintenant on va parler gaming et
performances vous avez un espace de jeu
dans lequel soient répertoriés vos jeux
vous avez l'accélération graphique vous
avez vraiment quelque chose qui est
complètement optimisé pib j'ai dû le
reconnaît directement avec une qualité
graphique élevé on entend dire quand
même qu'avec un instinct dragonne 710 ça
fait là faire franchement je trouve ça
hyper hyper fluide c'est vraiment
vraiment agréable à regarder
kim a ajouté je vais essayer de le
trouver et je veux le faire voilà
franchement par rapport aux instincts
dragonne 1145 comme ça en jouant pays
végète je trouve que graphiquement ça
fonctionne extrêmement bien c'est très
fluide ça réagit très très bien il ya un
très bon boulot de fait on va pas se
rendre vraiment compte de la différence
en termes d' usage quotidien sur un jeu
comme pdg ou alors sur la bureautique
sur ce que vous voulez pour envoyer des
mails pour aller naviguer sur instagram
et compagnie la vraie différence entre
instinct dragon's 710 soit sa dragonne
845 là dessus ne vous sentirez peut-être
à l'ouverture d'une application
peut-être lorsque vous avoir pleins
d'applications d'ouverte je me rende
compte alors bien évidemment se règle 17
pro va pas rivaliser en termes de
performances dans les moindres recoins
par rapport à un web plus si c'était par
contre je trouve que dans sa gamme de
tarifs qui s'en sort franchement bien le
stade dragonne 710 couple est assis giga
de ram fonctionne bien en plus en terme
de stockage 128g dia franchement vous
êtes tranquilles on peut mettre plein de
l'application peut mettre plein de
photos plein de vidéos avant d'avoir le
moins de problèmes là où je pense qu'
effectivement un truc qui coince un peu
mais c'est juste une question technique
c'est que sur le modèle moins haut de
gamme c'est à dire le rx 17 néo vous
avez la pousuite et d'avoir une carte
micro sd pour venir augmenter votre
mémoire jusqu'à 250 gigas alors sur le
modèle plus haut de gamme
vous ne pouvez pas j'en ai parlé avec un
des projets que manager de au pot qui
ont expliqué qu'ils avaient un problème
de place à priori dans la machine et que
dans le modèle pro il pas possible de
rajouter une carte microsd en plus bon
c'est pas bien grave 128 giga vous
pouvez déjà le faire mais c'est vrai
qu'on aura tendance à se dire que dans
un modèle plus haut de gamme
on devrait avoir plus d'options bon ça
une fois de plus c'est qu'un petit point
de détail en termes d'ouverture de
fermeture d'applications en terme de
navigation je trouve que il fonctionne
j'ai pas du tout de problème là-dessus
je trouve que il est même quand même
relativement fluide en termes
d'autonomie voulu garder pour moi une
bonne journée sans aucun problème là il
me reste 87% de batterie et la durée
estimée c'est un jour
14h58 alors un jour sans aucun problème
je vous donne un jour mais vous pouvez
atteindre un jour et demi voire deux
jours ça dépend complètement votre
utilisation si vous allez beaucoup joué
regardé beaucoup de vidéos faire
beaucoup de multimédia tout de suite
votre autonomie va fondre comme neige au
soleil si par contre vous relever d
email de temps en temps vous jouez à des
jeux mais sans trop abusé pour garder un
peu de réseaux sociaux passer quelques
coups de fil là dessus vous n'aurez
aucun problème pour garder deux jours en
plus un truc est hyper hyper malin vous
avez une batterie de trois mille sept
cent millions terreur mais en fait c'est
pas une batterie de trois mille sept
cent millions terreur vous avez deux
batteries de 1850 milan perd heure
chacun l'idée effectivement c'est comme
si vous aviez menti et directement
chaque batterie ce qui fait que temps de
recharge va aller beaucoup plus vite aux
trois quarts d'heure délai lui mettre
une charge complète ça doit même
beaucoup plus vite que la charge rapide
du one + 6 t et ça pour le coup c'est
vraiment bien c'est extrêmement pratique
parce que si vous êtes un gros
consommateur d'énergie
c'est un gros consommateur de
smartphones que l'autonomie pour vous
c'est vraiment vraiment important là
vous allez pouvoir brancher 45 minutes
et vous êtes reparti pour une journée
une journée et demie trip module photo
caméra 12 mégapixels une ouverture
variable comme sur le galaxy s 9
ouverture de f 1.4 et f 2.5 dont il est
vraiment excellent en faible luminosité
vous avez un deuxième capteur de 5
mégapixels ouverture de f/2 points 6 et
puis vous avez une caméra qu'on appelle
la caméra tough c'est la can et a time
of light qui permet de capturer les
scènes en trois dimensions ça pour
l'instant malheureusement ce n'est pas
encore dispo au point de vue logiciel
mais ça ne saurait tarder l'appareil
photo est d'assez complet il n'y a pas
beaucoup beaucoup d'options se perd pas
en tout cas dans les fioritures
d'options on va droit à l'essentiel et
bien évidemment du hdr une option qui
est intéressant ici c'est pour activer
de la couleur couleurs intelligent qui
va revenir complètement optimisé les
couleurs vous allez prendre donc avoir
des couleurs encore plus vive en gros ça
serait un petit peu le hdr de la couleur
c'est un traitement qui se fait une fois
que la photo a été prise
la marche très très bien la
reconnaissance de scène est idéale elle
ne reconnaît bien les ciels bleus les
plantes les scènes enfin ça fonctionne
vraiment vraiment bien reconnaissance de
visages qui marche très bien vous avez
bien évidemment un mode portrait
fonctionne très bien alors tu membres
pour toi aujourd'hui ça c'est classique
on connaît bien ça fonctionne
extrêmement bien très très bien des
tours et ça c'est aussi un point qui a
ses excellents et en plus vous avez
différentes possibilités au niveau des
éclairages de celles avec de la lumière
naturelle lumière de films lumière mono
lumière bicolore lumière toile et
éclairage par ce courage et c'est toutes
ces photos les temps poser exactement
que certains endroits c'est assez
glaçant et la mode portant qui
fonctionne aussi très bien avec la
caméra de sept films vous avez un mode
nuit qui vous permet de complètement
optimiser vos photos de nuit lorsque
vous allez faire des photos en mode nuit
vous avez une vraie optimisation ce qui
fait que bâle et lumières vont pas être
cramé tout va être vraiment hyper
équilibré
le problème c'est que fait un côté un
petit peu artificielle sur les visages
c'est tellement poussé que des fois
c'est un petit peu trop et on perd côté
naturel par contre le rendu est
franchement hyper hyper bluffant ce
smartphone en termes de photos de vidéos
il marche très bien photos de nuit
c'est vraiment incroyable les points
plus trop mais en tout cas ça marche
vraiment bien fait non on va les faire
un petit tour du côté de la caméra telle
fille voilà d'enjeu mais de l'autre côté
oui ça puis tu fais le tour vous avez
les deux faces d'une même pièce ça
fonctionne bien alors la brouille sur
les qui a peu caché par des arbres ça
fonctionne plutôt pas mal je poussais de
caméras et c réactive
c'est bien le
un vrai vous travaillez logiciel qui
était derrière les capteurs fonctionnent
bien pour moi c'est un smartphone qui
est assez équilibré les ce point de vue
là et ensuite des petits mode stickers
bon en plus sur la réalité augmentée
c'est assez marrant un loyer typiquement
je me transforme là c'est une petite
bête va envoyer un ça marche bien alors
on n'est pas sur une caméra trou d'air
comme sur les caméras des iphone 10
iphone 10s donc c'est une caméra qui
sera beaucoup moins pertinente par
contre bon ça marche quand même pas trop
trop mal c'est pas hyper hyper fluide
mais c'est assez rigolo en vidéo
maintenant vous pouvez filmer ans elle
fit en 1080p uniquement si par contre
vous voulez de la 4 car il faut passer
sur le capteur arrière et là vous allez
avoir la possibilité de filmer jusqu'à
4/4 usd autre petit détail cas c'est
sympa vous avez plusieurs modes vous
pouvez filmer bien évidemment en mode
standard mais également au ralenti et en
time lapse et vous avez un mot des
experts ou là vous allez pouvoir bien
gratté un petit peu plus dans les
paramètres vous allez pouvoir faire vos
quelques réglages et si toutefois vous
êtes un amoureux de la photographie
ça fonctionne plutôt pas mal mais
attention uniquement pour la
photographie il n'y a pas de mode pro
pour la vidéo à l'intelligence
artificielle je suis pas hyper hyper fan
les peaux sont un petit peu trop lisse
et vous conseille de le désactiver
à côté de ça ça marche extrêmement bien
la caméra de celle fille marche
extrêmement bien le traitement logiciel
au niveau du mode portrait est vraiment
bien ensemble en termes de photos vidéos
on a bondi pour un usage courant pour
faire des souvenirs film et ça marche
plutôt pas mal
pareil au niveau de la vidéo ça
fonctionne bien goupillé en 4k usd ou en
1080p ça va bon smartphone qui à 599
euros
je trouve qu'il ya un vrai bon rapport
qualité prix après il ya un point qui
est un peu litigieux fin que je trouve
un peu moyen c'est l'ouest je suis pas
fan de coloriage coloré 5.2 qui tourne
sur un android 8.1 oreo je suis pas
hyper fan bon ça fonctionne ya quelques
bonnes idées bonnes options jeu
peut-être trop habitués à certaines
autres surcouche peut-être un petit peu
le le problème là dessus
néanmoins tu peux pas leur reprocher que
ça ne fonctionne pas ça serait
relativement faut vous avez pas mal de
deux petites options vous pouvez venir
talonner votre écran avant des couleurs
un peu plus chaude un peu plus froide ya
pas de tiroirs d'applications saas est
un petit peu une habitude sur android ça
manque le fait se retrouve avec un opéra
ça aussi c'est c'est assez marrant mais
bon on peut très bien utiliser appris
votre google chrome comme vous le
souhaitez et colorés sont aime ou on
aime pas par contre une petite option
qui est assez intéressant cette espèce
de petit launcher sur le côté qu'un un
petit raccourci vous allez pouvoir avoir
vos applications les plus utilisées vous
allez pouvoir faire les captures d'écran
ici avoir accès à votre appareil photo
c'est un petit module qui est pas mal
qu'on peut activer désactiver comme on
le souhaite et lorsque le faire une
capture d'écran
ces trois doigts ça descend il faut même
faire une capture longue ça c'est cool
ça va vous rechargez tout votre page
vous allez faire une capture d'écran sur
l'ensemble de la page
ça ça fonctionne c'est plutôt cool voilà
pour ce test du r x 10 7 pro 2 au pot
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous aimez bien la marque au
pot est ce que vous trouvez que
l'arrivée d'eau pau en france avec son
finepix était bien est ce que vous
trouvez que l'ensemble des produits
présentés maintenant par opodo vous
paraît séduisant surtout qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ce produit le x10 est
trop on va tester le rx 7 neo d'ici très
peu de temps qui est un petit peu moins
cher que celui ci et qui promet d'être
vraiment aussi un excellent smartphone
dites moi ce que vous en pensez vous
marquez tout sans commentaire et puis
n'hésitez pas à les visionner ma
playlist pour aller savoir quel
smartphone acheté pour découvrir tous
les smartphones savoir lequel prendre
celui qui est intéressant oui mais
comment faille pas mal d'infos pas mal
de choses
vous invite à aller jeter un petit coup
d'oeil merci à vous d'être toujours plus
nombreuse toujours plus nombreux soit
issa je vous embrasse
et je vous dis à très bientôt ciao
non